bonjour alexis mais je merci d'être en
direct avec nous dans la matinale de rtl
france comme tous les lundis et alors on
va parler de la démission du général
lecointe un changement à la tête des
armées dans quelles circonstances le
général kittin ses fonctions alexis
alors il les quitte évidemment dans des
circonstances un peu bousculé comme ça a
été le cas pour le général de villiers
là il est question de la faim de barkan
sans préavis finalement il est question
aussi de cette tribune des généraux qui
appelait à prendre les responsabilités
face à un pouvoir politique devenu
finalement inefficients et puis surtout
il est celui qui ne veut pas être vue
comme un général politique c'est à dire
qu'il avait demandé à quitter ses
fonctions avant le 14 juillet 2021 il ya
déjà de cela quelques mois
et donc il est exaucé alors même que
emmanuel macron avait prolongé son poste
par décret pour qu'ils puissent rester
jusqu'à la fin de son mandat c'est à
dire faire le quinquennat avec lui mais
le général le cointre ne veut pas
surtout pas montrer qu'il pourrait être
un général politique parce que l'armée
doit être séparée bien sûr de la
responsabilité politique et obéir et
dans des circonstances d'ailleurs
particulière je viens de le rappeler sur
la tribune des généraux ou le général
lecointe avait condamné s'en sont
d'ailleurs aucune donc un doute sur le
fait qu' un militaire ne devait pas
sortir de son devoir de réserve pour
raisons politiques tant qu'il était en
active au même au delà puisque l'armée
ça reste la grande m et c'est le bras
armé de la république
emmanuel macron et et l'armée c'est un
rapport conflictuel ou bien une
incompréhension mutuelle
oui je crois qu'on peut parler d'
incompréhension et même peut-être de
conflits parce que on sent bien que chez
venelles macron il y a du mal à faire
corps avec la fonction régalienne du
président de la république chef des
armées mais aussi clef de voûte des
institutions
on le voyait lors de ses prises de
fonction il a commencé par descendre les
champs elysées en commande car le côté
bien sûr du général de milieux qui
parlait qui partait pardon quelques mois
après quelques semaines plus tard sur
fond de grave désaccord à propos du
budget de l'armée et la façon dont elles
macron se met en scène avec les
militaires il en fait des tonnes un peu
de
côté très militaire justement à regarder
dans les yeux les hommes virils et c'est
donc on voit bien qu'il a du mal et
c'est ce que dit le général lecointe en
disant que finalement il ya une
incompréhension peut-être générationnel
avec à la fois des journalistes mais
aussi des personnels politiques qui
n'ont pas du tout le sens finalement de
ce qu'est le sacrifice d'une vie au
service de l'armée française au service
de n'importe quelle arme et c'est à dire
être capable du sacrifice suprême pour
son pays et est clairement il y avait là
une critique à peine masquée du général
lecointe vis-à-vis des nouvelles macro
qui semble un peu trop léger je pense
dans la gestion des affaires régaliennes
de l'état
qu'attendre alexis de la dernière année
évidemment ii du quinquennat et quelle
place pour le thème de la défense
nationale dans la campagne selon vous
oui alors ça c'est une question qui va
sans doute aussi pesé dans la campagne
puisque le régalien revient en force que
soient les thèmes de sécurité de justice
et évidemment la défense en fait partie
la défense on en parle en ce moment avec
bien sûr l'avenir de l'otan quel va être
le rôle de la france dans ce nouvel os
tant la réalisation géostratégique mais
au niveau français tout simplement
quelles vont être les moyens alors on
voit que l'armée de son côté communique
beaucoup sur l'armée du futur tout ce
qui va être l'utilisation de drones de
robots de combat
il ya des exercices la semaine dernière
avec ces nouveaux robots armée capable
de d'être sur le terrain ou de dente
déminage et autres et puis il ya le
remplaçant de du général lecointe le
général burkhard qui lui est quelqu'un
de terrain qui a travaillé avec la
légion étrangère a asservi sur de
nombreux théâtres d'opération et qu'il
faut donc avoir une année pour prendre
ses fonctions et peut-être les continuer
en fonction de qui sera le locataire ou
la locatrice de l'elysée à partir de
2022 donc il va y avoir une vraie
question sur cette cette place de
l'armée au sein du dispositif bien sûr
français à l'étranger avec barkan
quelle est la suite des opérations
qu'elle au sahel on sait bien que les
poches terroristes n'ont fait que se
multiplier
et pourtant les morceaux nombreux
d'ailleurs avant son départ le général
lecointe il ira rencontrer les veuves
des militaires décédés au sahel et les
veufs également et donc il s'était en
cela qu'il disait il faut prendre
conscience de ce qu'est l'engagement
d'une vie pour l'armée
et on espère d'ailleurs que peu importe
qui sera le candidat mais c'est quelque
chose qui va évidemment pesé dans la
façon dont les programmes vont être
écrit et dans la façon dont on va
utiliser l'armé à des fins stratégiques
on va suivre donc ces nouvelles
relations entre le général thierry
burkhard et emmanuel macron merci à
alexis pour cet édito en reste avec nous
évidemment pour commenter l'actualité
politique du week-end et on va
solliciter votre réaction sur ces images
les jeunes qui ont été priés de quitter
les invalides à plusieurs reprises ce
week end ils ont fait la fête sans
respecter pour autant vous le voyez les
gestes barrière ambiance bon enfant et
la police qui évidemment est intervenu
pour pour les disperser
pendant ce temps là il y avait 30 40 à
roland garros seront qu'en dites vous
oui alors c'est l'image qui a fait
beaucoup de mal le soir de de roland
garros où il y avait un énorme match et
on avait donc le préfet qui d'un côté
autorisés à dépasser le couvre-feu pour
le match sachant le prix de la place à
roland garros et donc les profils de
people qui étaient là et qui scandent
merci macron et puis de l'autre côté les
jeunes qui en ont clairement album du
couvre-feu et de vivre de manière
contrainte depuis des mois qu'ils font
des fêtes sauvages aux invalides ils
l'ont fait deux soirs de suite la
troisième tout les accès de métro de la
place étaient fermés et à chaque fois la
même histoire c'est à dire que c'est la
police à coups de gaz lacrymogène qui
vide les fêtards de la place mais on
voit bien que pour la jeunesse c'en est
fini
c'en est assez je ne vois pas comment ce
couvre-feu à 23 heures pour être tenir
jusqu'à la fin du mois
les raisons médicales d'ailleurs de ce
couvre-feu sonçon questionnable alors
c'est un mix 1 il est question de gestes
barrières de vaccination de couvre-feu
pour que le virus finalement dégage de
nos vies mais sur ce qui est d'un couvre
feu
sachant que maintenant la fête se fait
en plein air la question se pose et
surtout la date pour quoi tenir encore
quelques semaines quelques jours alors
qu on voit bien que l' envie de
retrouver la vie pour les plus jeunes et
et ce sera le cas cet été
déborde déjà le risque c'est bien sûr
une reprise épidémique mais reste à
prouver que ce genre de rassemblement
créer des clusters et fait des supers
des événements super contaminateur qu'on
le dit visiblement en plein air ce n'est
pas le cas donc j'espère que
la connaissance du virus va avancer et
que les mesures liberticides qui parfois
sont très très loin de mesures
sanitaires vont disparaître que le
gouvernement sollicite maintenant à
partir de demain les jeunes pour se
faire vacciner vous pensez qu'il y à un
désenchantement face à la vaccination
que finalement les français en ont un
peu ras-le-bol on l'a vu là avec les
jeunes qui qui veulent faire la fête les
boîtes de nuit qui sont toujours fermées
et les jeunes qui sont sollicités pour
atteindre l'immunité collective c'est
compliqué oui c'est extrêmement
compliqué surtout que le bénéfice risque
alors pour un jeune personnellement il
est clairement pas forcément du bon côté
les jeunes ne risque pas grand-chose de
deux virus le risque évidemment qu'il
soit contaminants qu'ils véhiculent ce
virus mais vouloir vacciner les jeunes
pour atteindre l'immunité collective
c'est clairement une histoire
d'arithmétique de chiffres que les les
vaccinateurs du gouvernement
souhaiterait atteindre le plus vite
possible pour passer à autre chose
le problème c'est qu'en fonction des
souches des nouveaux variants c'est une
course contre la montre à savoir est ce
que certains vaccins seront efficaces
contre de nouveaux variants on le voit
en angleterre qui a massivement vaccinés
qui était un des pays qui avait le plus
vaccinée et bien le variant indien prend
le dessus et les contaminations
repartent à la hausse et en flèche
malgré la campagne de vaccination
massive donc cela pose question et puis
sur la jeunesse évidemment on n'a pas
forcément le recul nécessaire sur les
risques à long terme de ce vaccin sûr
que ce qu'en sera-t-il des prochaines
vagues et faut-il commencer dès
maintenant à vacciner les plus jeunes
il faut bien sûr le consentement des
parents il faut également avoir
suffisamment de recul sanitaire par
rapport à ce vaccin
aujourd'hui les études ont montré par
les laboratoires montrent des études
très limité sur 6000 jeunes qui ont été
vaccinés qui ont fait peu de cas mais à
partir du moment où on rentre dans la
vaccination de masse c'est là qu'on voit
les les cas plus plus grave plus délicat
de d'effets secondaires à la une des
événements politiques ce week-end il ya
également la marche des libertés qui
s'est tenu contre les idées du
rassemblement national jean luc
mélenchon de la france insoumise en tête
a été en farine et regardez et écoutez
le leader de la france est soumise
[Musique]
c'est une agression contre un droit
constitutionnel celui de manifester
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne veux
pas porter plainte j'estime que c'est au
procureur de la république c'est-à-dire
à l'état de dire s'il considère que
c'est un problème qu'on ne puisse pas
manifester sans être agressé si le
procureur estime que tout ça n'a pas
d'importance
le garde des sceaux en assumera la
responsabilité qu est-ce que ce geste
était une atteinte au droit de
manifester selon vous on a déjà vu que
ça s'est produit chez d'autres
politiques d'aidé en farine ajouter en
farine landry alors quelques jours avant
c'était françois de rugy en campagne qui
recevait un sac de farine également
choix que ces 6 ça fait partie de ce
climat de violence alors c'est une
violence symbolique l'allant farine âge
de politique mais d'un rejet finalement
de la représentation politique
le fait que les parties finalement soit
un entre soi de gens qui ne gère pas les
affaires pour le bien public mais pour
le bien de quelques-uns même si jean luc
mélenchon la france insoumise n'a jamais
été aux commandes
sauf quand il était ministre il ya
quelques années de cela mais il y à un
rejet du politique de la part de deux de
prendre désabusé on va dire de la
population alors elles peuvent être soit
aux extrêmes soit complètement désabusé
et rejeter le jeu politique tel qu'il
est et le risque c'est que sans débat
politique où se fait le débat finalement
comment arriver à a parlé et avoir des
élections il faut accepter quand même ce
jeu de la représentation politique si on
veut avancer
ou alors il faut vraiment revoir ses
systèmes et c'est autre chose donc
attention à cette montée des violences à
la fois symbolique par les mots mais
aussi physique par ces temps paris nice
cette gifle aussi contre le président
emmanuel macron à un moment il va
falloir revenir au calme on le voit bien
la justice a été saisie
le procureur a arrêté la danse farine
heures et il a été en garde à vue et une
enquête va être ouverte c'est le cas
également pour françois de rugy qui a
porté plainte et pourrait noël macron il
a été jugé en comparution immédiate ce
qu'il faut maintenant c'est de la
justice qui se de la justice sociale qui
soit la même pour tous c'est à dire pas
une justice d'exception pour les en
farine heures et les gifles heures mais
aussi que ce qui
ont été corrompus qui ont utilisé
détourné de l'argent public et bien
soient jugés eux aussi également et plus
rapidement ou bien ceux qui se sont
déguisés en policiers lors de
manifestations du 1er mai soit jugé mais
vous alexandre benallal c'était 2018 ça
commence à faire long pour un jugement
donc je pense qu'il faut à un moment
retrouver un semblant de débat et
surtout une certaine foi dans le
politique si ce n'est pas une fois au
moins une confiance qui a été rompu
depuis longtemps malheureusement comme
le montrent ces événements de violence
sporadique mais qui y sont réguliers
malheureusement cette cette violence que
vous décrivez pour vous elle va se
poursuivre pendant toute la campagne
présidentielle si rien n'est fait pour
rétablir la confiance oui je pense que
la montée de la violence c'est
inéluctable avec le risque comme le
disait jean luc mélenchon accusé de
complotisme c'est d'un événement majeur
ou d'un assassinat politique
on a vu jacques chirac président de la
république qui avait été visé par un
attentat par un tir de fusil lors du 14
juillet le 14 juillet c'est dans
quelques jours donc j'espère que la
sécurité de l'événement va être assurée
et de tous ceux qui participent
maintenant c'est aussi la sécurité des
candidats
quand on voit la facilité avec laquelle
jean luc mélenchon a été en farine et on
peut se soucie s'inquiéter de la
sécurité de la vie du candidat et des
autres candidats puisque c'est le cas
des colleurs d'affichés qu'il soit de
gauche de droite de n'importe quel parti
qui se font maintenant tabasser dans la
rue simplement parce qu'ils collent du
matériel de campagne politique donc on
ne peut pas accepter ce genre de
comportement dans une démocratie où le
débat doit être premier donc il faut
vraiment là que la justice comme comme
la police soit soit ferme et que l'on
rappelle tout le monde à l'ordre en
disant non ce n'est pas à coups de
farine ou à coups de poing qu'ont fait
valoir ses idées mais c'est à coup de
débats politiques aillent à 7 cette
infirmière qui attend le son verdict
aujourd'hui pour avoir lancé des
projectiles sur des policiers lors d'une
manifestation pour pour l'hôpital l'an
dernier il y à une tribune ce week end
de la maire de paris et d'autres
personnalités de gauche pour organiser
un référendum d'initiative populaire
pour l'hôpital est ce que pour vous
c'est une bonne chose
c'est encore des grand blabla comme
auquel emmanuel macron nous avait
habitués qu'est-ce qu'on en a à faire
d'avoir un référendum supplémentaires
sur l'hôpital on connaît les problèmes
de l'hôpital ça fait des années que les
urgentistes les médecins et les
soignants sont dans la rue pour dire
qu'il ya un manque criant de moyens et
de bras pourquoi vouloir encore noyé le
poisson avec un grand référendum une
grande idée de dire ah mais attendez on
va on va gagner du temps parce qu'on ne
veut pas vous
d'argent rappelez-vous les paroles de
françois fillon puis damon et le
maquereau aux infirmières quasiment
amber note qui disait on a besoin de
votre aide on a besoin d'argent et ce
que disait mâcon je vais pas faire de la
dette ma bonne dame est bien la dette
on est en plein dedans la dette qu'ovide
explose on n'a jamais trouvé autant
d'argent magique pour le coc vide alors
pourquoi on ne continuerait pas et
pourquoi
finalement on n'arriverait pas à sauver
l'hôpital ou du moins à sauver ce qu'il
en reste parce que le problème au delà
de l'hôpital c'est les services publics
donc je crois que ce faux discours du
politique qui finalement ne veut pas
faire le choix difficile l'arbitrage
budgétaire ou bien l'impôt
supplémentaire pour sauver le service
public qu'il se il se finit en blabla
inutile c'est le cas de ce référendum je
ne vois pas quel est l'intérêt pour vous
ce référendum d'initiative partagée
c'est finalement purement électorales y
foncez que c'était une revendication de
gilet jaune
oui mais s'il est complètement
électoraliste parce que je ne vois pas
ce que ça va changer aujourd'hui
notamment sur l'hôpital qu'on peut sans
référendum d'initiative partagée sur un
sujet plus complexes ou nouveaux par
exemple sur la proportionnelle pourquoi
nous n'avons tout nous toujours pas de
proportionnelle aux élections ce qui
fait que la représentation nationale n'a
plus rien de représentative
pourquoi on n'avance pas sûr évidemment
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne
davantage sur la démocratie directe
aujourd'hui on voit bien que là on fait
un faux référendum sur un sujet grave
qu'on connaît dont on connaît les
raisons les causes et les solutions
alors à part noyer le poisson de manière
électoraliste et dire je vous ai entendu
je vous ai compris maintenant je ne
ferai rien comme les autres je veux pas
qu'elle ait vraiment l'utilité
c'est un gadget s'il est utilisé comme
ça ça pourrait être utile si c'était
fait autrement
mais maintenant que les politiques
prennent enfin l'ont ils cessent de
faire semblant
merci alexis merci beaucoup vous avez vu
on avait le temps ce matin pour parler
politique
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse ce
matin dans la matinale de rtl france